décès du fils m'a fait chier mais il
avoue une chose des imitations c'est un
sacré bien il avoue que je fasse bourvil
or si je le fais pas il est méchant
segment des imitations de te regrette
c'est que t'as pas parler de ta femme
pascal est un amour de femme et qui ne
l'a pas rendu hommage à un million il
est taclé mais c'est toi qui lui rend
hommage elle est très belle et et c'est
bien foutu chez toi hein
j'avais fait jamais venu chez moi tu un
char ou
comme tu sais ça
ben ali et pia travées quand t'étais pas
là y'a pas toi qui bouffent des minots 1
est venu chez moi
ce calcul où il tentait de chez moi
un jour tu n'étais pas là d'ailleurs
brillé le redis pascal spieser ça
maintenant qu'on l'a pas dit il décode
tgb de la maison d'ici ici il est là le
petit buffet empire à l'entrée de
vide-poche et tout est à une
reproduction de le noter de van houtte a
écrit la bave de damien hackett qui sort
de son corps je suis passé un soir où tu
étais pas pardon je voulais te saluer
t'étais pas là pascal m'a offert un
verre on a passé une soirée formidable
non mais c'est bizarre parce que je
pouvais être ici
puis découvre que ta femme te trompes là
aujourd'hui
avec elle c'est bizarre qu'il n'est pas
si étonnant parce qu'effectivement j'ai
un petit guéridon j'ai un show kerhornou
on se connaît pas suffisamment pour une
sage également les télégrammes botella
tu as faim
[Applaudissements]
alors là c'est le terrain on voit ton
vrai visage
est arrêté mais s'il est un battant
antoine tu veut l'appeler la pala
appelle là je sais pas où elle est en
pleine mais non mais tu as quand même
heureux des lardons et crac boum tina
oui c'est vrai qu'il
[Rires]
attendait la tournée la journée cette
émission est basé sur la discrétion tout
le monde le sait on va s'arrêter que ce
fichier
avant toi
antoine robert ouvert
alleyrat bien
bon j'aime j'aime beaucoup bassij
étaient bien
juste le faire a juste un peu de sart
passer pour un con bon ben voila je vais
prêcher la part dont jeanne humour un
peu limité c'est pas grave ça robert
romer
revient robert o le malaise
c'est la seule femme bien encore à
l'arrêt olivier les rené en toi est ce
qu'il ya des choses que vous avez dit
que vous regrettez d'avoir dit non non
non je ne regrette que laurent ait dit
ça antoine mais de ça ça va revenir
comment s'est passé l'émission
magnifiquement bien présent très bien
mais ça directement bien content ça vas
y à rien et je suis ravi d'être face à
quelqu'un que je lisais ya 35 ans même
plus dans rang ken folk décembre les
scieries ardisson faisait avec jean-luc
met des interviews grandes gueules à
l'époque si ces descentes de police
étaient arrivés
[Applaudissements]
alors le droit de salir avec une fois
mais qui est toujours de bonne humeur
ben voilà il a droit de s'énerver une
fois dans sa vie mort de georges excusez
moi
il va arriver aulas bon pardon pardon
voyez des choses de
bon en dehors de ces incidents
je regrette qu'il n'ait pas fait bon
vivre
je m'excuse et moi je sais ce que tu as
dit quoi on était bien et on était très
très bien reçu un très bien reçue à ce
qui s'est passé
il t'a fait mal
imputées
à rhône non je regarde pas avoir dit à
laurent baffie que c'est un modèle pour
moi parce que je trouve très fort depuis
que je suis tout jeune et je suis
toujours impressionné par sa son sens tu
vois laurent
[Applaudissements]
en continu continu c'était le bihan et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de dinars
10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais un peu
ce bleu